der Punkt ist doch wir brauchen echte
Fachkräfte und meine These ist dass uns
vor allem die Ampel mit einer völlig
absurden Zuwanderungspolitik
konfrontiert im Moment das wird immer
über Fachkräfte zuwanderungskonzeption
wird es dann immer verkauft und
letztendlich ist es nichts anderes als
eine Politik der offenen Türen die eine
ganz gefährliche Konsequenz in jeder
Hinsicht hat erstens sind es gefährliche
Anreize in die Krisenregionen das machen
sich Menschen auf den Weg die sich
besser nicht auf den Weg machen sollten
wir erleben das Sterben im Mittelmeer
das viel größere Grab in der Region ist
die Sahara und die ist richtige Signal
wäre eigentlich in alle Teile Afrikas du
brauchst dich nicht auf den Weg zu
machen weil du nach Europa nicht
reinkommst die Ampel ist Geisterfahrer
in Europa alle europäischen Länder
fahren mittlerweile eine sehr
restriktiven Asyl Kurs auch eine sehr
restriktiven zuwanderungskurs und die
Ampel Schere dort aus was im übrigen
auch zu Irritation bei unseren bei
unseren europäischen Nachbarn führt und
was das Thema Fachkräfte Zuwanderung
angeht da kriegen wir dann immer auch
von Heil erzählt ja und wir brauchen
Fachkräfte und wir haben jetzt genau die
optimale Variante damit ihr alle zukommt
zu uns kommen das Problem ist aber dass
alles in einen Topf geworfen wird die
Fachkraft die Arbeitskraft und dann gibt
es am Schluss auch noch den Spurwechsel
von Asyl rüber in den ganz normalen
Arbeitsmarkt und das ist brandgefährlich
wird dann am Schluss noch garniert immer
mit dem Vergleich zu Kanada mit dem
Punktesystem Kanadas man kann Kanada und
das deutsche zuwanderungssystem nicht
einmal im Ansatz vergleichen oder
signifikanteste Unterschied ist dass in
Kanada ein Großteil derer die vor der
Tür stehen wirklich arbeitswillige und
Großteil Fachkräfte sind und wir haben
bei uns nach wie vor zu viele Menschen
die Sicherheit wollen die aber auch
soziale Sicherheit wollen und die sich
am Ende eben nicht in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt einbringen
Friedrich Merz ja heute zum
flüchtlingsgipfel der Unionsparteien
geladen glauben sie dass da auch Thema
ist wie man Fachkräfte nach Deutschland
bekommt wie man qualifizierte Fachkräfte
bekommt also bei dem Gipfel denke ich
wird vor allem mal Thema sein es gibt
ein offenes Mikrofon das mal die
Oberbürgermeister und die Landräte
schildern können dass einfach das Wasser
mittlerweile Oberkante Unterlippe steht
es gibt keine Unterkünfte mehr kann
allein Möglichkeiten mehr die Menschen
unterzubringen wir hatten vorhin das
Beispiel dass das natürlich dann in
einem kleinen Ort auf Widerstand trifft
wenn der 150 Flüchtlinge auf 400
Einwohner stoßen das ist eine untragbare
Unterbringungssituation wir haben keine
Plätze in den Kitas keine Plätze in den
Schulen und ich glaube das heute vor
allem mal die Oberbürgermeister und
Landräte ihrem Ärger Luft machen werden
weil sie völlig allein gelassen werden
sie alle haben kürzlich den
flüchtlingsgipfel mitbekommen für mich
ein Manifest der ergebnislosigkeit und
eine fest der Tatenlosigkeit und so
werden wir nicht weitermachen können
weil diesen irrsinnlichen Kurs den Baden
am Schluss die Landräte die
Oberbürgermeister und vor allem die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus muss
vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen gerade
die Bundespolizei mit denen ich einen
engen Kontakt habe haben seit einem Jahr
bundeszentrierter immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass die Situation eskaliert
ist die Zahlen im Vergleich zu den
vorherigen exorbitant wieder ansteigen
auch bei schlechter Witterung auch im
Winter und haben immer wieder darauf
gedrungen dass endlich etwas passieren
muss und diese Briefe und und brandmails
muss man fast sagen wo überhaupt nicht
beantwortet in der Öffentlichkeit äußert
sie sich komischerweise immer anders
zuletzt will sie jetzt plötzlich hohe
Zäune bauen aber in der Realität kommt
davon nichts an und dass ein
riesengroßes Problem gerade die
Bundespolizei sagt wir können an der
Grenze viel mehr tun da kommen wir
gleich noch zu dem Thema Grenze das ist
auch ihr Thema Frau Gastgewerbe gleich
noch mal ganz tief reingehen ich möchte
einmal beim Thema Fachkräfte auch
bleiben aber was glauben sie ist
Deutschland überhaupt noch das große
präferierte Ziel für qualifizierte
Fachkräfte ja andreas hat doch kürzlich
zwei wichtige Zahlen gesagt hat gemeint
dass im vorletzten Jahr eine Million
Menschen nach Deutschland kamen auf
verschiedenen Wegen übrigens überwiegend
nicht auf dem Weg Asyl und das im selben
Jahr aber auch 750.000 Menschen wieder
gegangen sind und das natürlich schon
ein Problem wir IAB hat kürzlich auch
dargelegt dass wir ja etwa 400.000
Fachkräfte brauchen jedes Jahr und diese
Zahl erreichen wir jetzt gerade nicht
das zeigt schon dass mit der
Attraktivität irgendwas da hängt
irgendwie es fehlt noch bei der
Willkommenskultur Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen bei generell der Anerkennung
der Leistung
familiennachzugsfragen und so weiter und
so fort das heißt es sind ja die die die
die Fakten wo andere Länder tatsächlich
besser sind und deswegen auch das ich
melde mich auch das wird mich mal
interessieren ja
skandinavischen Länder in vielen
Bereichen aber ich weil sie gemeint
haben viele Facetten und eine Facette
ist aber auch dass die Wirtschaft die
Hoffmann gerade angesprochen hat auch
bei mir Hände ringend immer wieder
anruft und sagt okay wir brauchen wir
haben die Hälfte unserer Stellen in
Bayern die die schwer oder gar nicht
besetzt sind das würde mich
interessieren was sind das für stellen
was brauchen sie für Arbeitskräfte wir
es gibt einen weiten Bereich man kann es
nicht so nicht nur sagen nur Menschen in
die eine Ausbildung machen technisch
nicht technischen Berufen oder nur
Akademikerinnen also darf man auch nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen auch da eine
wichtige Botschaft brauchen wir beide
und ich glaube dass wir gerade die
Demografie als unsere Berufe welche
Branchen wo fehlst da besonders in
vielen Branchen aber tatsächlich also
wir haben es gerade schon gehört beim im
Bereich der Pflege
obwohl da noch mal eigene Probleme im
Hintergrund stehen da geht's auch viel
um gute Arbeit gute Arbeitsbedingungen
Handwerk ähm und all unsere
Zukunftsbranchen die wir in der
Industrie auch haben muss gerade noch
mal dazwischen mal sehen Sachen
Skandinavien er ist ein Vorbild Schweden
ist das unsicherste Land Europas weil
die genau diese Politik gemacht haben
die gerade ihre Ampelkoalition macht
nämlich Türen auf und gucken was
passiert Schweden ist gefährlich als
Albanien die haben die höchste Mordrate
in Europa die haben gerade Rolle
rückwärts gemacht und versuchen jetzt
mitfahrzeugen massiv dagegen genau
dagegen zu steuern ich glaube auch was
jetzt auch gerade wieder nicht so
deutlich wird der Herr von der CSU hat
so ein bisschen versucht wir haben doch
drei Säulen und darüber wird überhaupt
nicht gesprochen es wird immer vermischt
wir haben einmal Zuwanderung die wir
brauchen aber von qualifizierten
Menschen die wir uns auch aussuchen
dürfen wen können wir gebrauchen wen
brauchen wir hier wen wollen wir hier
dann haben wir das Asylverfahren da
gibt's Menschen und dann haben wir aber
auch illegale Migration und da haben wir
rechtsstaatliche Verfahren ich glaube da
sind wir uns ja alle einig wir haben
einen sehr funktionierenden Rechtsstaat
und wer in diesem Rechtsstaat einfach
nach mehreren Verfahren und endgültig
gesagt bekommt du darfst nicht bleiben
der geht aber nicht nach Hause und das
ist unser großes Problem wir vermischen
drei Säulen die wir haben und dass wir
ein Zuwanderungsgesetz seit Jahrzehnten
brauchen auch an ihre Schwesterpartei
und sie haben sie auch nie geschafft in
der großen Koalition nicht wir brauchen
das seit 20 Jahren dass wir Menschen
nach Deutschland holen die wir aber auch
hier brauchen wir glauben immer über das
wir machen die Türen auf und gucken mal
was kommt und ob wir dann damit
klarkommen müssen wir sehen dazu kommt
die Tür ist einmal auf wer hier ist und
das wissen sie auch im Moment der bleibt
auch hier im letzten Jahr 36.000
Menschen sollten nur abgeschoben werden
obwohl 300.000 gehen müssen wie viel
sind gegangen 13.000 weil die Menschen
einfach entweder bekommen sie ist
angekündigt sie schmeißen ihre Ausweise
Weg sie werden dann kriegen ein
Nervenzusammenbruch bei der Abstimmung
sie randalieren am Flieger und dann
passiert eben nicht und das heißt wir
bekommen immer mehr Menschen ins Land
und für die die wir brauchen die wir
wirklich dringend brauchen da sind wir
glaube in der Runde einig die wir
dringend brauchen wir gar keinen Platz
und Möglichkeiten mehr weil die die wir
gar nicht hier haben wollen alles
blockieren und da tut einfach die Ampel
überhaupt nichts wie gesagt noch sagen
ja von den 2015 gekommen eine Menschen
sind die Mehrheit inzwischen in Arbeit
25%
25% von den von denen im arbeitsfähigen
Alter 55
ja aber das ist ja bei uns wir haben ja
auch keine Erwerbsquote in Deutschland
von 100% im 55%, da sollten wir fanden
ich habe den Fakten check hier dabei und
den kann ich ihn später auch noch mal
zeigen
55%, aber denn und das ist viel höher
als in 90er die aus dem ehemaligen
Jugoslawien hierher geflogen warum weil
wir Dinge ermöglicht haben weil wir ihn
ermöglicht haben in Arbeit zu kommen und
wir sehen uns auch bei den Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainern da sehen wir es ja auch da
haben wir bei über einer Million wenn
die Zahl so stimmt also inzwischen ja
auch schon über 100000 Menschen in
kürzester Zeit Ukraine und woran liegt
das weil die natürlich in einem anderen
Rechtskreis die sind ja ausgenommen die
dürfen sofort die dürfen wir sofort in
einer Ausbildung und die dürfen sofort
an die Unterwäsche immer das Argumentes
deswegen oder dafür aber die bringen es
gibt verschiedene aber denen sofort die
Möglichkeit zu geben dann wird die von
vielen vielen von den allermeisten noch
angenommen auf jeden Fall das ist ein
gefährlicher Anreiz weil sie am Schluss
schaffen sie ein Konjunkturpaket für
Wissen das aus vielen Bereichen dass
wenn dann gleich wenn zum Beispiel
jemand nach Deutschland kommt oder
kannst sofort arbeiten dann wissen die
auch dass das sofort die Schleuser
Dienste bezahlen kann
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie